On Veterans Day, I would
like to recognize and thank
our nearly 1800 veterans
who are students,
faculty members, and staff
at the University of Arizona.
Thank you so much
for your service.
Thanks for your service.
From me, and from
the OSIRIS-REx team,
thank you very much
for your service.
Thank you for your service.
To all who have
served or are currently
serving in the military, we'd
like to welcome you to U of A.
You bring unique experiences
to the rest of the students
and a level of maturity
that is unparalleled.
So on this Veterans
Day, from all of us
at the University of Arizona
and the wildcat family,
we want to thank you for your
service, your leadership,
and your courage to simply
make this world a better place.
[MUSIC PLAYING]